find out for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week first up
healthy aging having high blood pressure
and more stiffening of the blood vessels
are often seen as inevitable byproducts
of aging but can they be avoided a new
report published this week in the
journal hypertension examined data from
over 3000 people who are part of the
ongoing Framingham Heart Study all were
age 50 or older overall they found that
only around 18 percent were considered
to exhibit healthy vascular aging CBS
News contributor dr. Tara Narula is here
to tell us more about that study
welcome doc good morning out so first
off what is considered healthy vascular
aging right so we've become used to this
idea that well as we age our arteries
age they become stiffer and we develop
high blood pressure but that doesn't
have to be the case and when you look at
more traditional hunter-gatherer
societies that doesn't happen so there's
something about our Western lifestyle or
diet that's causing this
so in this report they defined healthy
vascular aging as a blood pressure less
than 140 over 90 and people who were not
on blood pressure medication and
something called a pulse wave velocity
that was less than 7.6 m/s what is a
pulse wave velocity well is it every
time the heart beats and contracts it
generates a energy wave that travels
down the circulatory system in down the
vessels if you measure that velocity
from one point to one point that will
change depending on how stiff the
arteries are so the stiffer the arteries
the faster the velocity so this is how
they looked at that in this report it's
I'm interested only about 18% we're
considered to have healthy vascular
aging how does that break down in terms
of ages well it doesn't look good for us
as we get older and it is more
challenging especially when you're over
70 so when they broke it down by age
they found that about 30% had healthy
vascular aging in their 50s that dropped
to about 7% in your 60s and only about
1% in the 70s at healthy vascular aging
is improvement possible or is this an
inevitable part of the aging process
that's one of the good things about this
report is that it gives us hope that yes
it is possible if we alter our lifestyle
and so they found that by keeping
yourself trim having a lower body mass
index avoiding diabetes and having
healthier cholesterol you
be more likely to have healthy vascular
aging if you're able to meet the life
simple seven that the American Heart
Association has as goals if you've got
six out of seven of those you are ten
times more likely to have healthy
vascular aging as opposed to people who
only had zero to one of those goals met
and why is this important well in this
report they found that those who had
healthy vascular aging were 55 percent
less likely to develop cardiovascular
disease it's an important statistic
moving on to our next topic how willing
are we to share our health information
with those closest to us a newly
published survey commissioned by Orlando
Health looked at that question comparing
results for both men and women the
survey coincides with the drive for
Men's Health Initiative which starts
today two doctors will hop in a car
traveling 3,000 miles to promote men's
health Tara when it comes to willingness
to discuss certain topics I'm guessing
women are better than this than men you
would guess correctly yes so we know
that there is a gender divide when it
comes to this and you know there are a
lot of theories as to why this might be
and some people say well it's because
women are used to getting preventive
care from the time they're younger they
get pap smears they take their kids to
the doctor and men just don't have that
same concept from the time they're
younger but it is really important and
across the board in this report in the
survey they did find that men were less
willing to discuss things with their
family members like high blood pressure
like cancer like mental health issues
but it's it's valuable thing because
when you discuss these things with your
family members you learn about your
family history you learn about what your
risks are so you can take preventive
steps in addition you get support and
social support is so important your
family can say I will go to the doctor
with you let's remember to take your
medication we know that people with
support systems do better so very
important what topic most deeply divides
the sexes in terms of discussion well
there was one topic where they found a
big divide and that was sexual health
and especially in the ages of 18 to 34
yeah they found that women were about 34
percent likely to discuss sexual health
in that age range and men were only
about 18% likely so you know the the the
doctors who are doing this drive they
are using social media they're under the
hashtag what's under your hood and they
they say that this is very unsettling
that question well you know they're
pretty reveal hood that men are very
good about taking their cars to get
maintenance okay look under the hood but
they're not so great about treating
their body of the chassis yeah that's a
correct breakdown dead ahead all right
finally the first Saturday of each month
brings our practical advice segment
health situations we all encounter today
managing your medication Starr what are
some tips that people can keep in mind I
love this topic so much because it's so
important so set timers set yourself
reminders I like to tell patients keep
your medications where your toothbrush
is where your breakfast cereal is so it
kind of is a reminder as soon as you go
in that area you also want to get early
refill so you don't run out maybe ask
your doctor for a 90 day supply of your
medications you want to schedule medical
check-ups with your doctor to go over
your medicine so to talk about side
effects to talk about timing so for some
medicines like statins or cholesterol
medicines you have to take them at night
for other medicines like proton pump
inhibitors nexium and stomach acid
reduces you have to take them in the
morning
you also want someone who can sit there
and say with you well these meds might
interact and you know not everybody is
looking at that other things don't just
stop your medicine if you don't like it
or if you're having side-effect a lot of
patients do that call your doctor and
say I'm thinking I should stop this and
then most importantly really keep a list
of your medications I had two patients
yesterday who would have had very good
strategies for this one opened up his
phone and showed me an app that had a
list of all his medications I said
that's brilliant
and the second one opened up his phone
and had taken pictures of all his
medicine bottle art I thought this is
perfect you don't have to bring them in
just show me the photo so it's really
important because lots of times they'll
show up in the ER at a doctor's office
and you say what medicine you're taking
and they say the little yellow pill
right I have no idea what that would be
now this little thing it's blue right
what's the dosage I have no idea you do
not want to find yourself in that
situation keep the corn pops and the
prescriptions near each other or take
photos of them dr. taryn Narula thanks
for your time thank you